okay we have to talk about this new
narrative that is being created by Trump
supporters that all the polls are
fabricated and skewed towards Hillary
Clinton yesterday I told you that
Hillary Clinton is now leading 16 of the
latest 16 polls nationally of the
presidential election and every time we
do this I get emails from people saying
David don't you see what's going on the
liberal media is skewing the polls to
make it seem as though Hillary is
waiting now not only do we have no
evidence of that wouldn't that be kind
of stupid Louis because if you want
Hillary to win skewing the polls to make
it look like she is winning actually
puts at risk that Hillary voters will
stay home thinking she doesn't need
their vote it's a very dumb strategy if
that's what you're trying to do yeah I I
don't see and I don't see how it would
be beneficial to those who are doing the
polling and putting this information out
doesn't make any sense and nate silver
wrote an article i'm sorry/not nate
silver on nate silver's
fivethirtyeight.com this morning an
article was written by one of the other
staff writers basically debunking what
is being used as the explanation for why
these polls are biased and what a lot of
right-wingers including the queen of the
birther movement orly taitz i'm on her
mailing list only because i can't
unsubscribe i've tried to get our
mailing list a dozen times you can't do
it you just can't do it so I get her
mailings she is critical of the sum of
these polls by saying Democrats are
oversampled if you look at the
percentage of people in the poll that
are Democrats it's way higher than the
number of Democrats that are actually
registered and what is not understood by
people like the queen of the birther
movement or orly taitz is that the
pollsters don't weigh the results by
party self-identification and what many
people don't know is in the polls
they're often as which party do you
identify with this is often different
than actual party registration and this
little detail seems lost on many people
like orly taitz they're being asked
which party do you identify with oh I
identify as an independent I identify as
a Democrat this is very different than
how people are registered and
Kentucky is a really good example
Kentucky has way more democratic
registered voters the sort of Dixiecrat
Blue Dogs etcetera but when you actually
look at how people vote it is much more
conservative and fivethirtyeight.com
does a really good job of explaining how
you can't just look at a poll and see oh
they have thirty-seven percent Democrats
even though democratic registration is
thirty-two percent or whatever it is it
really doesn't tell you the story when
you consider identification and
registration are very different things
yeah and and and what would be the
motivation and how would fabricating
polls yeah uh help these pollsters in
the future it just really doesn't make
any sense there's no reason to do it
there there just is no reasonable reason
why you would do that and there are
repercussions when pollsters are really
wrong right there are posters from the
twenty twelve election who were just way
off and they're no longer included in
averages of poles RealClearPolitics for
example does an average of polls to give
you an overall picture of how things
look they decide which pollsters to
include based on track record and
there's really no advantage to just
making up polls there really is not
gamefly is sort of like Netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4
ps3 wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low use price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30-day trial at
gamefly offer.com / TDPS the games are
shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30-day trial for
the david pakman show audience and
support our show by going to gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s